all right
hello everyone uh i am james snell
uh and i am the head of research at
uh near form and i am a node core
contributor tsc member
uh and i am going to be talking
hopefully the the sound is is all right
i'll be talking about
aligning node.js with the web platform
uh so uh basically you know what does
this mean
um well yeah there's there's there's a
question that's been asked for
for a while now uh uh a number of years
should node.js implement the same apis
as the browser
when i got involved with uh with node
core back in 2015
uh you know there was this constant
refrain um
as i was getting started from other node
core contributors that node's not a
browser
it shouldn't implement the same apis you
know node runs on the server
it's a different thing uh yes it's
javascript in both places but just
you know ignore that fact and it's just
different
it has a whole different set of
requirements um
so you know it's you know for for all
this time there's been this
argument just th this this this idea
that you know these are two completely
separate things um
and uh they're they're they're they're
really not
uh they are they are they are quite
similar um
and there there is a significant area of
overlap
there we go so there is this this
significant
overlap so we have this one you know
what i call this this gulf of unsameness
between
between these that that you know that is
perceived
it doesn't actually exist so if you're
thinking if you're looking at node if
you're thinking of browsers you're
saying these are completely different
things
they're not related to another they
shouldn't implement the same apis
that is fundamentally the wrong way to
think about it instead what we have
is an overlapping um uh
an overlapping space here where there
are some things that are unique to
browsers some things that are unique to
node but there is an area where they
overlap
we're talking things like event loop
scheduling we're talking things like you
know handling urls or
http client requests there are things
that that
you know that developers do in both
environments and it makes absolutely no
sense for these to have
completely separate apis a completely
separate way of doing things
so what we've been doing here recently
with node um
is going through and actually looking at
the
at the web platform apis all of the apis
that exist in the browsers today
and seeing which ones make sense
for node to implement uh and there's
gonna be a lot there
uh there's a ton of apis available in
browsers that just don't make sense
for a server-side node environment
uh uh one you can imagine are you know
apis for reading device sensors you know
battery levels and all these kind of
things
it's just not something that that is
needed in node or even dom rendering
it's not necessarily something that that
we need in node
but those existing browsers on the node
side there's apis there that
you know that belong there uh things
like you know an http server
right or setting up um uh you know a dns
server or something like this
things that that only should exist on
that server side
don't exist in browsers so we're not
going to i don't think we're ever going
to see a case where
the two environments implement all the
exact same stuff
but this area in between all right where
they do share functionality
uh where they uh uh where developers
have to do things in a consistent way uh
you know just makes
life easier for for the developer if
they don't have to kind of paper over or
polyfill
or or account for the differences in
these different environments
uh the the analogy i like to use
is you know when all of the browsers did
things differently when you had yet you
know ie6 and
safari and firefox and they weren't
aligned on these apis right and you had
to write code that was specific to i
you know internet explorer or whatever
right yeah we all remember the uh
you know the notices this website you
know works best in internet explorer
we don't want to get back to that kind
of uh um
that kind of thinking we don't want to
prolong that kind of thinking there are
areas where these things go together
so we started this process a couple of
years ago
and the first kind of browser api that
we
introduced into node not without its
share of controversy
was the u it was the what wg url uh
object uh up until that time
the way that we did url parsing and node
that we had this url.parse uh uh
method and a couple years ago we had you
know a few reports that it was actually
mishandling things like
um user ids uh uh
passwords that kind of thing yeah in the
url so if you had something like you
know
a username and the password
at you know at whatever domain
depending on how the username and
password were uh
were specified url parse would handle
that incorrectly and you get some wrong
information there's a few other bugs
in the implementation as well well
rather than
go through and fix those because the
the implementation of url parts is
actually quite incredibly complex in
order to get that performance out of it
um i took a step back and said you know
what let's actually do something
completely different
let's go ahead and start this alignment
with the note with the browsers
and actually just implement the new url
object uh the ww2 url object in node
itself
and now today it sits there side by side
with url parse url parse is not going
anywhere the old you know we call it the
legacy api it's not going anywhere it's
going to be there
um probably forever but now when you
want to actually work with urls
you have the same api uh as you have on
the browsers
compatible to the specification uh we
run the same web platform tests
um that you know that the browsers do to
verify it uh we work with the what wg
url standard when we when when changes
need to be made
and we're keeping this in you know uh
two pace with with what browsers are
doing
in fact i'm happy to say in some ways we
are actually more spec compliance
than some of the browsers uh with this
url
uh so it's there it's been there for um
a number of years and should be
supported in every version uh all the
supported versions of node today
uh another example that we started a
couple years ago was
the text encoder and text decoder now
really this is just you know a way you
know taking a typed array
encoding it or you know to you know
utf-8
or uh you know any any number of other
texting codings and back and forth
between those it it takes the place
uh we're the same basic role as when we
say buffer from
and you have some bit of text let's say
this hello is a buffer from and we want
to convert that from utfa
it serves the the the same basic role of
that
but it uses that standard api that is
defined by
the ywg encoding standard and
implemented in the browsers
so it's been there that's been there for
a couple of years and now um here
recently just tonight is
as a matter of uh uh two weeks ago uh we
did land
finally btoa and a2 uh
hb uh uh implementations in node so
those will be coming
uh in in is part of node 15 within
uh the uh is part of the buffer module
so it'll just require buffer btoa to
access it
uh in node 15 and then hopefully node 16
and beyond
uh those will be global just like they
are in the browser
uh now it's a minor thing uh and in our
documentation we actually say
you know they're here but you probably
shouldn't use them they're old apis that
you know they're they've only been added
for to have this this cross-platform
compatibility um
but the but yeah it's actually better if
you still
use the buffer apis for doing base64
encoding
uh when you are focused uh strictly on
the node environment
uh and and and just as a side note node
also now understands
url safe uh base64 now this is in a a
a browser standard i just wanted to
point this out
uh but you know we've always had base64
in there but if you now use this base
explore url you will get that the url
safe encoding
for um you know for that data so
very useful but text coders have been in
there again for for
you know a a number of years it's uh it
should be supported in all
all the versions of node that are all
the lcs versions actually out there
um more recently we started another
effort and this was
uh uh you know last year uh 2020
where we introduced event target
uh to node as well now node has always
had
events emitter uh and has always been an
event
model like everything in node is an
event emitter
for for emitting these events handling
them
doing whatever you want with that um but
this event target has always existed in
the browsers
as the way of doing events in that
environment and you know there's a lot
of similarities
um you know there are some very real
differences between
between the models but they basically do
the same thing they handle events
dispatch and handle events
um and you know and it really just
didn't make
sense to keep avoiding implementing
event target
in node um uh you know especially when
we get to some of the later use cases
which i'll which i'll talk about in a
minute
um so you know it was let's just go
ahead and do it
uh implement event target implement
event yes it duplicates event emitter
but that's
okay uh and so we have this there are
some differences from what's in the
browser um there's no such thing as
hierarchical event bubbling in node um
we don't have a you know this
hierarchical dom model that we need to
work with
uh so it just it you know it's just not
necessary
to have that node in in very little uh
uh
there's very little in node that would
lend itself to requiring that hierarchy
but we can create an event target you
can create an event object dispatch it
handle it you can create your own
custom event objects pass those around
uh it's the same api uh as
yeah as in the browser and again we we
verify that using the web platform tests
uh the same tests that the browsers use
to verify uh
their compliance so that's there that's
available now
um and probably i think it's only in
from node 14 up it may not have made it
back to uh
to node 12. so it may not quite be
available for everyone yet
but but it's there and it's common now
one of the primary
use cases of uh of event target
fluorescent node
is uh is for the abort controller
implementation
now anybody that's familiar with the
fetch api and browsers is
you should be familiar with the abort
controller this is the means
of just bailing out and aborting uh the
http request
that fetch issues within node we are
going through and using you know we
decided to
use a board controller and abort signal
as kind of the
idiomatic standard way of uh canceling
asynchronous operations uh pretty much
across the board and we've started a
process of integrating a board
controller and abort signal
signal throughout uh many core apis
uh child process when you exec a file uh
or you know or four can spawn a new
node process you can pass in an abort
signal and use that
uh that api to to cancel it uh file
system like if you're reading a file
sending it you know uh connecting to an
http server um
listening for net requests right um uh
you know or when you're you're working
with streams a weightable timer gdp data
graph
yeah throughout all these different
places you're starting to see
signal abort signal uh be supported
now the abort controller or the abort
signal is an instance of event target
and it is the first case uh where we
have a
implemented event target as opposed to
uh event emitter
and the reason for that is uh uh
is spec compliance right we you know we
don't want to just
implement apis that are like what you
see in the browsers
we want to implement the same apis in a
standard way
so that they work consistently across
these in different environments and only
where the semantics of the implemented
implementation
have to differ is where we want to and
or you know we're going to call out
those differences very very clearly
like the lack of hierarchical bubbling
and event handling
all right if it just doesn't make sense
in node
then we won't implement it and then you
know and and we'll
very clearly call those things out
now just to give you an idea of how this
works we also have this notion
uh recently added notion of a weightable
timer so you
uh uh you can basically have a version
of set timeout that returns a promise
uh in in this particular example we
create the abort controller i'm creating
a race between
two of these set timeouts one it's gonna
wait one second the other's gonna wait
two seconds
the one that waits one uh signals an
abort and notice that in a second
we're passing the abort signal uh uh
in so when the yeah in this particular
case when
the abort signal is uh import
controllers is is
uh uh is triggered right the second
timeout is going to bail out early
with an error uh until you know you know
which we handle by just saying hey
okay this is the board right so this
pattern whenever you see this signal uh
option
right you know that's the kind of the
idiomatic way that we are
setting this up to where you can cancel
these asynchronous operations
uh uh throughout note okay
um now that's you know support for this
is it you know varies there's some of
this in 14
um you know there's some being added to
15. i expect a lot more to come in
in in note 16 it's going to take some
time to get all the you know all these
apis
uh supporting us so just you know look
for it
and give us a bit of time and one of the
other
classes that we have that implements
event target is message channel
this is uh you know this is introduced
part is part of the worker threads
support so no node now has multiple
threads it's an api that's similar
to workers in the browser but not quite
the same but it allows one-to-one
message passing back and forth
uh with the uh across these threads uh
the message port
is a uh is an event target
uh you create the message channel this
is the exact same api that you can use
in the uh
uh in the browser uh and we use this for
our
messaging back and forth
all right so another example we have
is broadcast channel whereas
met yeah and broadcast channels is a new
api even for browsers not
you know it's not well known it's not
out there uh
you know too much but it does exist
there
and where the difference between message
channel and broadcast channels where
it's message channel is one to one
broadcast channel is one too many so any
uh broadcast channel object you create
that points
you know that references the same uh
channel name
right is going to receive a copy of that
message
right so you know here we're creating
two
uh and and it doesn't matter these can
be in different uh worker threads so i
you know i could spin up
you know i can spin up a hundred
different worker threads all of them
having their own broadcast channel
do a single post message and all of them
will get that message
uh so it makes certain a very flexible
way of
of passing the data around um this
is uh again the same api um it works the
same way
in node as it does in the browser now
the one difference with browsers
is that the broadcast channel name space
is based on the same
origin right so you know if you have
worker threads
that all exists with the same uh uh
uh you know origin space those will
receive the messages whereas a node
there's no such thing as an origin it
the namespace is process wide
so uh any you know any bit of code in
the
in that note process can create the
broadcast channel connect to the same
um uh uh to the same channel name and
receive that data
so there's again some slight semantic
differences
uh where they make sense but the api is
the same
now another one uh and a much larger one
that we that we added recently uh this
is uh last year's part of note 15
is node now implements the web crypto
api
uh again same api that exists in a
browser
how we get to it is slightly different
all right so in the browser
you would you know you have a crypto
global
and you can just go you know crypto dot
subtle and
generate key that's how you do it the
browser in node
uh you import web crypto from the
existing crypto module
uh and that web crypto object maps to
uh the the the you know the same crypto
object
that you would have in the browser okay
so from there you have
a subtle um object you can
request you can get random values
all right yeah and from that point on
it's the exact same api that
what you have in our browsers so here
what we're doing
uh in this example we're creating an aes
encryption key uh important thing here
is
these are asynchronous operations um the
the key generation the encryption the
decryption happens off the node event
loops so these are non-blocking
operations
um they uh there's some slight
differences between existing crypto
module and node
um uh in terms of identifiers or you
know some of the behaviors
um this was written to match what uh
uh what what is required by the web
crypto spec and what runs in the browser
we are currently working on introducing
the the web platform tests for the
browser into node to verify
uh the web crypto implementation uh web
crypto is still considered experimental
in node so there could be some changes
that we are going through and working
through some bugs
um uh but yeah you know as that matures
what i expected node
sometimes in the node 16 time frame is
that web crypto will graduate to fully
support it
all right so uh and you know just again
carrying through now this code
um with like i said with the exception
of how we get a reference to the web
crypto
this web crypto object all the rest of
this code
should work exactly the same in the
browser as it does in node and back and
forth maybe
and be completely portable
all right so there's some other things
that we're working on um
and you know this this is a a
a very experimental one uh within node
um or within browsers if you're familiar
with fetch or if you're familiar with
some of the
um the objects that implement readable
stream
um and your file you know the file apis
then you may be familiar with this blob
object
uh a blob is essentially kind of an
opaque
um uh data buffer
um it is immutable once it's created so
unlike a typed array where you can get
to all the data and you can manipulate
the data
right it's you know when the type rate
is not opaque you can
you know you can dig into any part of it
a blob is considered opaque
and immutable once it's created you
can't change that data
there's no accessors for the individual
bytes it's just
there you do have ways of reading from
it using you know this.text or dot
arraybuffer
there's ways of getting to that data uh
but the data itself
is immutable uh blob is one of the ways
with fetch that you can read the
contents of the
um of the request you just made of the
response
uh there is a experimental
implementation of blob
now in node um um i i think it's out in
in note 15 right now uh it
currently only supports the um uh
static data um uh so all the data has to
be available when the
blob object is created one of the things
that we need to do next
is to have it support a dynamic data
source where the data is streaming in
such as from an http response or from
you know reading a file uh that work is
will be coming within the next you know
weeks to
a couple weeks to a couple months
somewhere in there uh depending on the
prior yeah
how we can prioritize out that that time
blob is one of well i'd say
blob uh uh event target um
uh yeah these things are part of the
effort
to eventually get to a
fetch implementation uh in node
um a lot of folks have asked us about
fetch
uh they want to see it um we don't have
i don't have an example for fetch yet
why because implementing is quite a bit
more complicated than it seems
there's a lot we have to figure out and
there's other stuff we need to have in
node before we can do a a proper fetch
implementation
what wg streams finishing blob getting a
form data implementation
right we've got to figure out what we're
going to do around cores hp caching and
hp state
um all things we currently don't do in
node at all figure out a more seamless
hp version discovery and interrupt
between hp 1 2
and 3. um uh so we need to you know we
need to figure all those things out so
fetches is coming we just have work to
enable it
so if you're hoping for fetching node it
uh you know yeah i'd be happy it it will
be there
hopefully this year in the meantime go
look at it
so that was a quick uh you know
whirlwind summary of
of things that we're doing with that
node to align it with the the web
platform
i know i want to do that quick so any
questions feel free to reach out to me
if
if you want more information i'm happy
to chat
thank you